ah
my God
sorry oh that's on my feet [__]
I'm sitting around over here
so I almost looks owe
oh my God
how are you your hair looks awful today
you've been up all night owl
oh it's usually more cloth
hmm
what have you got to say for me today
huh
I don't know what to make of you today
huh I don't know what to make of you
today why not you have energy today
that's good because I'm not because I'm
not
because I'm on drugs huh because you get
some sleep in the hotel room last night
but I just wanted to call you I was just
watching out fashion shows all night
do you get me a room how'd you know I
was at the hotel
good what do you think's paying for your
room huh who do you think's paying for
your room you're not paying for me
Continental you get kicked I did no get
me a room forever oh forever it's like a
month I could do that okay thank you
foreign
I'll pay for a room permanently for you
thank you
feel my life if you do that oh
okay
what did you do after night oh
[__]
what did you last night what did I do
last night I
what did I do I had dinner with my
daughter and I went to bed what
restaurant did you go to jail went to
Jelena huh no no no I went to uh
it went to air one it was Italian
huh it's a grocery store what did you oh
okay it's a high-end grocery store
vodka why are your feet so beaten up huh
why are your feet so beaten though what
I can't hear you why are your feet so
beaten up because I was walking on glass
last night owa I was going on Barefoot
and just left everywhere
vodka
[__] you know what I hate life pain I
don't understand it it's very
unnecessary you have a very low pain
threshold I see I I do I don't
understand people who don't I mean I'm
very oh
I mean I'm very like I procrastinate a
lot anyway
but like I don't want it there you know
I mean I don't get it what are your
worst qualities
um I'm very like um like I need to get
it you know I mean I'm very impatient
I'm very messy
I'm very lazy yeah it doesn't matter
what it's qualities
you're honest how you're honest uh Mark
I can't help it doesn't make sense what
do I lie about
might be humble in life oh
this is why I got nothing going on
anyway
that's what people like about me
honestly most of my authenticity right
you're very intelligent
I want I don't think I'm an idiot [__] I
can't remember that's not a cracked the
book I didn't even finish High School
let them go to college where did you go
to college
University of Illinois for a year I went
to Northern Illinois for a year I went
to Columbia College for two years what's
it called I'm sorry what's it called
Columbia oh Columbia New York and
Chicago different school okay wow what
did you study oh
Columbia studied uh photography
photographer what's that who's your
favorite photographer we talked about
this before Dennis
Dennis monarchy he's a photographer in
Chicago
a lot of people
do you know Stephen Klein is I do you
know Steven I do I love Stephen I have
myself I love Klein
actually a drop in fashion
I just ah being a bum you know what I
mean so here's here's what you should do
here's what you should do Rebecca no
Mark here's what I need to do I need to
get a job I need to get a house
a phone it's also income I believe you
could make money sometimes somebody
rehab [__] they try to make me go to
rehab
rehab the drugs are a big part of my
life let me put my personality
you [__] virgin get my [__] together
but I can't because I don't even have
identification I'm not even a citizen
how many other [__] together then stop
complaining about actually do something
about it [__] if you stop talking I
could give you a plan that could
actually help you mark my plan is
Continental
and help me get a job [__]
does that not make more sense
[__]
if you if you could somehow
document your life
for me on social yeah I am right now
I'll hand it off to you and then you can
take the ball and run yeah Mark I'd love
to act or [__] sing or whatever [__]
I'm not a terrible actress but social
media is a powerful tool you can make
money with it I got some I know I'm just
not an opportunistic person I don't even
need money for that much I'm not I'm not
like that you know what I mean
I mean
being sub being a celebrity it's like in
my nature
like it's not just you know people are
like I can handle it you know it's just
it's just who I am
like I go everywhere people look at me
I'm Gonna Take My Photo it's always been
that way I just comes naturally to me so
that means in the industry Mark okay
[__] we're not like you [__] virgin
go to amping get it rehab what the [__]
can we take off the glasses no please no
what all right come on
100 I'll take them off
a hundred dollars deal
die [__] you have to break them you
just take them off
they're 20 [__] they're made to be
broken
uh my feet ah
it's gonna ruin the area [__] huh
you're an interesting somebody somebody
came by and brought these clothes for
you when you were gone
no no no [__]
hmm
what the [__] is us
no
Envy is okay no not myself for all the
people that want to donate clothes to
Rebecca now you see what it is yeah I
know why that's a bad idea get me in
contact with America
I close in a house I mean I can't
remember last time I ate [__]
[__] I get out of the trash Mark I
offered to buy you lunch yesterday yes
you bought me lunch people back to the
lunch I think you marked up
your hair got messy huh your wig got
messy yeah I know more I live on the
street
there's a brand new it was a brand new
wig yesterday huh it was a brand new wig
yesterday yeah it's a win [__] I live in
life
what did you do to mess up your hair
that uh Mark I live my life [__] oh look
at you
complain much
what I party [__] [__]
ing I'm glad you're wearing underwear
huh I'm glad you're wearing oh you're
not in my underwear yeah I hate no I
hate not wearing underwear I hate my
penis [__] I just really need a sex
change [__] it's so in the way you know
what I mean
like oh
[__]
I want an apartment in West Hollywood
can you get me an apartment in West
Hollywood
what is that hour
[__]
it puts the lotion on the skin or it
gets the hose again
[__]
it does she just went out about
Hollywood people I was recording movies
what's your favorite movie
I think I'm a pretty classic I like The
Godfather I really I don't like I think
it's too like it pounds like there's
more violence or more gangster I think
it's too like like like legally like
lawyer like it's too dynastic I know
I don't love it honestly
like there's way like 80s movies like
there's a great Terry Gillian movie that
I love called Jabberwocky oh I've never
seen that one I've seen Brazil and I've
seen the imaginary rocker pronounce this
I hated both well I kind of like Brazil
but
I saw this year's theorem I didn't care
for it anyway
I don't I don't like them you know I
like surrealists but with him for me
Owen
[__]
everybody should obviously [__] like why
is this my life you know what I mean
like why can't I just like have a
boyfriend an apartment a career you
probably could yeah that would be a good
idea but you just can't I'm out here
running some dumpsters
[__] eating trash wearing trash
don't say you're still laugh Market
because I lost money
does crystal happen oh [__]
you've done cocaine never what you look
at you you're getting cocaine anyway you
know what I mean what you sound bored or
[__] around you right
I've never smoked pot why not
you're in L.A it's impossible
I'm so [__] virgin that's why exactly
because you don't do drugs you don't
like to do drugs doing drugs that you
enjoy your life
it's like going out for a nice bite to
eat you ever been a Spargo Iowa many
years ago huh many years ago yeah I
really want to get a smoke time and
pizza up so I know I made it in L.A [__]
I just want to respond that one
mark
okay
[__] I can't live like a bum I'm not
late for it I swear I don't care you
know I mean I'm Egyptian hour [__]
I'm gonna kill this [__] bro
you can't shoot the [__] I had [__] I
got a gun
you always want to be a serial killer
it's not what I didn't mean you know
what I mean like I don't care you know
let me give you some shoes
yeah I need shoes buy me shoes [__] you
know my shoes yesterday why not ow I was
trying to buy you shoes yesterday you
can't Mark you were out of your mind on
whatever you took fine you know because
I don't like that part of town [__] I
took you shopping you took something
while we were out and you changed your
whole person I didn't mark she did
hour of sober I was having a panic
attack [__]
ow just stay in your room I'll get your
room for the rest of the month okay fine
daddy [__] you'll be my little uh
thank you boy I'll be your sugar daddy
I'm just very happy that we don't [__]
honestly we don't I think we're friends
I what happened to you but I'm happy we
don't should you find me attractive
no I find you super attractive but but
not I'm not sexually attracted attracted
to man yeah you don't like dick I don't
you know what I mean it's it's um it's
exotic
to me are you a hood girl yeah I know
I'm a bad person not a hot girl I'm I'm
too bougie I wish I oh I wish I was hurt
like I don't know how to fight you know
ah
[__]
[__] my life
well maybe maybe having a room over your
head will help you yes it will Mark okay
I'll take care of you consider it done
okay yeah we're neighbors now that'll be
nice [__]
you're very like Midwestern honestly I
am uh where are you from proud of it
Chicago Detroit all right yeah I love
Chicago yeah that's like a 40s feel to
it you know
there's like a luxury there you know
what I mean I'm a Chicago boy huh I'm a
Chicago
oh I don't know like I just kind of
walked around there
[__]
looks like it's like World War Two World
War III down there [__]
oh [__]
you need to rest your feet
Mark I told you I
oh [__]
[__]
that's funny to you with that no I love
you I love the way you look right now I
hate not wearing shoes
like I don't know if you're fascinated
by aren't you the brutality of it you
like like the poverty like you think
there's a charm to poverty
you think there's an authenticity it's
not the poverty part of you that I find
fascinating well I do something about a
[__] [__] I don't know how to [__]
I wasn't like
I was actually raised that way you know
what I mean
ah [__]
your parents have no life skills you
know what I mean
[__]
this is what concert feels like you know
what I mean having to fight your own
body I never understood like how's that
even possible okay I'll get your friend
free freda's number again
I keep calling her [__]
Joe my only friend
ah she's the only friend of yours that I
have a number of yeah you got her on
Facebook which is really creepy I don't
know how you do that Owen she contacted
me
yeah I love her
remember Daria
yeah she was like honestly like she's
one of those girls like she loves me I
don't know like
it's really fascinated by me in a really
weird way kind of like you are you know
what I mean yeah I think I think most
most of your most of my audience that
likes you or is female I think yeah what
because I'm a girl you know girls girl
you know what I mean like I like I
wouldn't appear oh man
I get it you know I mean I love Bros I
don't want to bro you know I definitely
a woman
and women love like women you know what
I mean
ow
[__]
so if you think I got stabbed you know
what I mean
oh
do you imagine what it'd be like to have
a roof over your head a bed a shower all
that stuff
thank you I would love to yeah yeah oh
yeah I've tried many times but you
always disappear um no you didn't you
never offered me a full room and I did
stay in the room Marcus I go out [__]
I don't think Iowa you still have your
phone huh you still have the phone again
no I don't it didn't work okay it
doesn't work
it didn't work what are you talking
about no it don't work really it's it
just died for some reason ow
I have like a [__] like a brown thumb
when it comes to technology I don't know
why all my phones are breaking right I'm
very reckless
in general like a big phones I break my
[__] house keys
ah my [__] mess I [__] love it but
you know
it's not exactly yeah
convenient oh [__]
I never worked in my life I didn't know
how to you know you've never had a job
huh you've never had a job in my life
never I don't know how but this has
never happened to me
that's kind of why I'm homeless I don't
even know how to get a job but I don't
know what I I would do I'd love to work
in fashion but I think it was fashion is
like I'm a bum right now and
like I work out I don't know how to drop
it I don't know how to apply for a job
and I didn't go to college but you're
certainly talented and interesting and I
think social social media would be a
great place for you to like okay then
I'll do it [__] do that yeah I'm not
gonna [__] I don't care [__]
I think people would follow you and uh
you'd eventually build a following and
you'd have uh I would have a YouTube
endorsements for money oh [__] God
vodka
gonna stop my feet off maybe that would
stabilize your life a little bit
well that becomes a job Mike I don't
know why you're giving me advice I don't
actually do anything about it you know
what I mean it's like you're complaining
I'll give you a place to do it I'll give
you a phone can you give me some water
I'll get you a walk like a soda or
something that you sold in there [__]
I don't know [__]
[__]
we're colder one I don't do coconut [__]
it's water oh yeah
oh
oh water in a can thanks Brad was it joy
joy and joy joy
no I don't know who somebody gave
you ever see that movie Joy with
Jennifer Lawrence never seen it huh
never seen it what's the last movie you
saw
[__] what I just I just watched
coming back from Afghanistan I watched
uh you went to Afghanistan yeah with
Lauren huh with Lauren with Lauren your
daughter no Lauren is a girl who I've
interviewed like
no why yeah uh to do interviews really
I don't actually watch your [__] I mean
I never have a phone so I don't know and
you seem to do International chat you
know there's also crap [__] suited I
mean like when I got a proper Studio I'm
sorry how do you do it to like
how do I do what how do you get people
to do the interviews with you [__]
that's that's part of the I know Java
guy like did you put up odds you know oh
the internet I have some funny people
all different ways many different ways
yeah like what like kind of oh [__]
oh [__] like how you just approached me
you know what I mean is that what you're
doing it I was like I know a little
Tokyo he's not a bomb but he wants to
come do interviews with you tell him to
come over yeah oh [__]
oh
[__] God
gonna [__] kill myself I [__] hate
this [__] I mean the good thing about
your feet hurting is that you probably
won't walk too far so the hotel room
will work at least for a few nights is
it because you're paying for it like
what uh
my [__] I had to party I like to walk
around do things with my life no but you
could document your your am I sitting in
a hotel room no you can document your
party you could document your party
shut the [__] up you need you could walk
you document your partying and you're
walking around try to curtail the drug
use a little bit
about drugs okay Dad you'd be
fascinating no I wouldn't Mark I'm on
drugs I'm fascinating on drugs okay
stop it no but I've seen you clean
you've been no no you haven't you've
said you've sat here when you're clean I
am never cleaned around okay you're
paying money to buy drugs okay all you
want to go to drugs okay close I find it
I'm sorry okay I am drunk hi my name is
drugs okay
honestly what is your problem with drugs
[__] you look cool you sound like
Crystal right [__]
[__]
I don't want you to change
I'm not judging you [__] virgin
what an L.A [__] [__]
have you tried any trucks in life never
why not
it's not my thing
well try it you know
it's like is this it just elevates you
know what I mean do you drink
I haven't had a drink in a while what do
you usually drink I don't like alcohol
either I don't like this thing of it you
know hour
[__]
when I'm with somebody and she's having
or he or she is having a dream for a
white wine or red wine
uh red yeah me too oh
Spanish red ones are good oh what
the [__] is this [__]
ah can you go shopping right after this
do we what if you go shopping I need
some recently I'll take another shopping
huh what do you what do you I'll take
you shopping what do you want oh
a couple bags I don't know
let's do it okay
gotta go right now
it's gonna work on my feet first time
[__] yeah
because I'm on drugs [__]
you're on drugs different yesterday
no I wasn't Mark I was sober
out
of water
there's I need to push it for my ear
[__]
huh give an endorsement to Joy water you
guys have to do it endorse him
[__] I know my feet
enjoy water
for the luxury like I don't [__] I've
been on toddler in a while I wonder if I
could do advertising you know what I
mean
because I don't think I have like a
conventional look
foreign
nice to see you
I don't know
he's kind of messed up today it's
you are a little messed up today
where have you been
I'm just just around
you disappeared
I got you a hotel room for a couple of
nights
and you split
I'm sorry I
you see that this life is not going to
take you anywhere right
you see that this life this way you're
living is not going to lead you to
anything that you want right I don't
know
if you want a career in fashion or you
want to be a star you want to be a
celebrity or whatever you want to be
none of that's going to happen
with what you're doing
you're you're only belonging is a
blanket
do you have shoes
I'm sorry I'm I'll do better
I think you might need some help Rebecca
I hate to be someone who's always
harping on you to do things but but when
I see you like this I just don't know
what to say
huh
I hate to be a friend who's always
harping on you
saying that you should do this or you
should do that but when I see you like
this and you can barely speak and you're
walking around shoeless without anything
but a blanket
I know I'm sorry I'm just I don't I
don't know
let's try to look at what's going on
here
there's drugs right
no
um I mean not right now but normally
there are drugs involved right no I mean
I've been sober for the last few days I
mean
only because you don't have money to buy
drugs right no it's not like cotton
I have a feeling Rebecca that there's
something that went on in your childhood
that you're just having a hard time
dealing with
and a therapist can probably help you
with that I'm not saying one or three
times but you know seeing a therapist
regularly can really help you I think
because you're 25 now you're going to be
35 in a Flash
and you'll still be on the Street
Homeless shoeless
living like a
Street person
you could be doing so much more
you could be living a great life right
now
I know I know yeah
all the things you dream about those
could be a reality
I know
thank you
I'm sorry I'm not using Lexus I just I
don't know
what do you need right now you need a
bed to sleep in you need a shower you
need a shower I can tell you that
you need some clothes
yeah definitely yeah I just need to get
it cleaned up and and fix things
I'm not sure the hotel across the street
will let you back in
after what happened last time
but maybe they won't recognize you
without the wig
I'm sorry what are you going through
mentally
I don't know just kind of
I don't know
where have you been the last week or so
huh where have you been for the last
week
you go to West Hollywood
I I don't know it's just around there
guys I don't know
I wish I could help you somehow
other than buying new phones that you
lose
I wish I could help you somehow other
than just buying you things that you're
going to lose
I'm sorry I'm
can you imagine
a different life huh for yourself
a life where you're
doing something you enjoy doing that you
where you have a job that you go to and
yeah you're fulfilled and successful
you're
yeah or you're stimulated and challenged
and you're enjoying it I can and I think
a lot of the viewers can too yeah me too
yeah
I think a lot of people can see your
potential
sorry
you look good I think
I'll be better I promise it's okay
you don't have to be I don't want to put
pressure on you to do anything
I'm sorry
let me try to get you a shower
in a room and some clothes
all right and we'll see where we go from
there
all right my view okay
okay